[Musik]
jetzt live aus köln der presseclub mit
volker herres
hallo und herzlich willkommen schön
sonntag aus köln schön dass sie dabei
sind beim ard-presseclub auch heute
müssen wir über putins krieg in der
ukraine reden er stand ganz und gar im
mittelpunkt des gipfeltreffens in dieser
woche in brüssel zu dem auch us
präsident joe biden angereist war nato
g7 eu selten gab es derart viel
einigkeit und geschlossenheit die
ukraine wird gegen den überfall
geschützt mit geld waren und waffen aber
ein direktes eingreifen ins
kriegsgeschehen das schließt die nato
weiter aus und auch auf gas und öl aus
russland wollen die eu-länder noch nicht
völlig verzichten sondern sich
schrittweise unabhängiger machen reicht
das kann der russische präsident so zur
umkehr gezwungen werden oder eskaliert
die lage noch weiter
das feindbild das den westen einst alle
gegen putin drei gipfel viele beschlüsse
mehr soldaten an der ostflanke europas
militärische abschreckung die usa
verhängen neue strafmaßnahmen gegen
hunderte russische abgeordnete vom
westen soll ein zeichen von stärke und
geschlossenheit ausgehen
putin hat darauf gesetzt die nato zu
spalten bei meinen gesprächen mit ihm es
im dezember und anfang januar wurde mir
klar er dachte nicht dass wir weiter
zusammenhalten können die nato war
niemals mehr vereint als es heute der
fall ist
aber die eu kann sich nicht auf ein
sofortiges gas und öl embargo
verständigen für die ukraine mit einer
milliarde euro unterstützen militärisch
und für den wiederaufbau russland fast
all diese maßnahmen als bedrohung auf
sagt der besten aber den totalen krieg
erklärt
disco und verstecken nicht ihre zieht
die wollen die russische wirtschaft und
russland als ganzes zerstören brechen
vernichten erdrosseln red skull
kleineres schiff zu die westlichen
staaten haben ein signal gesendet wie
wird putin jetzt darauf reagieren
mehr geld mehr waffen mehr soldaten was
stoppt putin das ist unser thema darüber
wollen wir diskutieren und das sind
heute meine gäste stefan kornelius ist
ressortleiter politik der süddeutschen
zeitung erschießt nicht aus dass ein in
die enge getriebener putin auch eine
taktische atomwaffen zündet und beklagt
die deutsche verzagtheit und
risikovermeidung
sie hat als korrespondentin für den
stern aus moskau und aus washington
berichtet katja gloger ist bei uns
profilierte kennerin russland
journalistin und autorin unter anderem
einer biografie über wladimir putin von
dem sie sagt er habe mit seinem
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine auch die
zukunft einer ganzen russischen
generation zerstört
im krieg so heißt es stirbt die wahrheit
zuerst ich begrüße julia smirnova die
gebürtige russin arbeitet für die
unabhängige denkfabrik asd dem institute
for strategic dialogue und sie
untersucht die verbreitung von
desinformation zuvor war sie moskau
korrespondent in der welt und berichtete
über die krim annexion und den krieg in
der ost ukraine und udo lielischkies war
langjähriger leiter des ard-studios in
moskau er ist autor des buches im
schatten des kreml unterwegs in putins
russland und er fürchtet dass keine
sanktionen des westens auch nicht ein
importstopp für gas und öl putin stoppen
wird seien sie alle herzlich willkommen
und noch ein hinweis für sie liebe
zuschauer via stream in dieser sendung
live in mehreren sozialen netzwerken und
freuen uns auch auf ihre meinungen und
fragen zu unserem heutigen thema release
wir haben gerade in der tagesschau
gesehen der krieg geht weiter in der
ukraine brutal auch gegen die
zivilbevölkerung aber wir haben es auch
gehört die ukrainische seite meldet
erfolge und aus moskau hören wir es gebe
einen strategiewechsel man wolle sich
jetzt ganz und gar auf die eroberung des
donners konzentrieren zeigen die
ukrainische widerstandsfähigkeit und die
westlichen sanktionen da bereits wirkung
ja man muss sehr vorsichtig sein was
konkrete situation angeht es gibt
erfolgsmeldungen aus person etwa das ist
schwer zu überprüfen man beide seiten
haben ein interesse daran ihre eigene
situation zu beschönigen das muss man
auch für kiew sagen das soll die
kampfmoral befördern aber das große bild
glaube ich es schon klar die russischen
truppen haben massive probleme bedingt
auch durch schlechte logistik sie waren
nicht vorbereitet auf diesen langen
krieg die ukraine gehen sehr sehr
beherzt und und strategisch klug vor und
bremsen an verschiedenen orten sehr
erfolgreich aber es gibt auch wieder
meldungen über angriffe der russischen
seite jetzt im don was zum beispiel auch
mit dem einsatz von phosphorbomben wenn
es denn zutrifft alles was wir
diskutieren muss man immer mit einem
gewissen vorbehalt tun weil es ist
wahnsinnig schwer wirklich die die ganz
konkreten situation zu beurteilen heute
ist das zu viel ist wie ein
spiegelkabinett aber das große bild
kriegt allmählich eine gewisse form auch
die zahlen der gefallenen oder der der
verwundeten russen das nährt sich schon
einer dimension an jetzt die
ungewöhnlich hoch ist sauer und damals
mal so gibt das mal an sie weiter voraus
mir noch was wissen wir tatsächlich
stellt bewusst an den anfang der sendung
weil wir diskutieren über eine lage aber
im krieg muss man immer wissen wie
verlässlich sind die informationen die
wir haben herrn erlischt die zeit
angesprochen die russische seite hat
jetzt von
1350 getöteten russischen soldaten
gesprochen wie muss man das irgendwie
müssen wir diese informationen insgesamt
einschätzen tatsächlich ist es schwierig
im krieg die informationen zur
überprüfung in vielen fällen in einigen
fällen ist es möglich
aber was wir auf jeden fall beobachten
vor allem auf der russischen seite eine
starke propagandakampagne und ich würde
jetzt nichts
hier russland und die ukraine
gleichsetzen die rosco propaganda hat
ein anderes ziel eine andere qualität
unter ein anderes aus das ziel der
uganda ist in diesem fall die invasion
die ukraine das töten von tausenden
menschen zu unterstützen die hochschule
hat eine andere qualität
wir haben in den vergangenen jahren
mehrmals gesehen dass russischer
staatsvertreter und russischer
staatsmedien bereits dazu bereits und
bereits bewiesen fakten zu leugnen zum
beispiel nach der kommunikation oder
das war auch der fall mit der
beteiligung große schüssel daten zu
beginn des krieges kloster gehen und
jetzt auch mit dem angriff auch die
geburtsklinik schon mal jubel das heißt
wir müssen uns bewusst sein dass diese
propaganda kampagne läuft auch am besten
sagen sie bei 1 unwägbarkeiten und
unsicherheiten also das vertrauen in
informationen der ukrainischen seite
kann etwas ausgeprägter sein als das
gegenüber der russischen seite oder
müssen wir gleichermaßen misstrauisch
sein die ukrainische kommunikation hat
ein anderes ziel die
länder versucht einen angriffskrieg zu
rechtfertigen und die ukraine versucht
da geht es tatsächlich um die moral der
truppen
es geht tatsächlich um andere ziele und
auch in anderen methoden ich möchte auch
gern dem andruck vorbeugen dass man das
gleichsetzen kann auf gar keinen fall
auf russischer seite ist die
desinformation natürlich um ein
vielfaches größer es gibt ja auch viele
journalisten aus dem westen die aus der
ukraine berichten denen wir in aller
regel jahren ziemlich über den weg
trauen also der eindruck entstehen dass
ich weiterhin als zurzeit aus es gibt
eine tendenz zur beschönigung aus kiew
das ist klar aber grundsätzlich glaube
ich kann man deren aussagen deutlich
besser vertrauen sie werden auch immer
wieder belegt danke für die klarstellung
herr cornelius ich glaube viele
vielleicht sogar wir alle waren
überrascht über die stärke und das
durchsetzungsvermögen
der ukrainischen armee bei einem solchen
überfall einer militärischer
gigantischen überlegenen großmacht
wie ist das heute einzuschätzen halten
die das noch lange durch haben die
tatsächlich die kraft einen solchen
überfall zu überstehen
tatsächlich ist die die taktik des
ukrainischen militärs bemerkenswert weil
man das in einem land krieg dieser
dimension noch nie erlebt hat im prinzip
ein organisiertes partisanen tun jetzt
bereits in diesem krieg sie abarbeiten
die operierenden großen verbänden es
gibt keine panzerschlachten sie
operieren den kleinen gruppen die
tatsächlich mit diesen waffen die ihnen
vom westen geliefert wurden sehr
erfolgreich sind also die
panzerabwehrwaffen und die diese hand
gehalten mit hand gehalten
flugabwehrraketen wie lange sie das
durchhalten ist natürlich die schlüssel
frau an und das hängt schlicht davon ab
ob die nato ob der westen sie weiter
beliefern kann da befürchte ich vermute
dass wir in einer zeit also gar nicht
mal so langer zeit an
versorgungsengpässe kommen vor allem
nicht nur vielleicht mit waffen sondern
auch mit ganz banalen gegen treibstoff
nahrungsmittel essen medizinische
versorgung
die ukraine spürt jetzt bereits dass die
nachschubwege
komplizierter zu bedienen sind wir sehen
die angriffe auf lift die
natürlich nicht nur die depots zum ziel
haben sondern auch die nachschubwege des
westens und ich finde es sehr
interessant wie genau kalibriert der
westen die nato
mit diesem krieg umgehen dieses gerede
dass wir nicht teil des krieges sind ist
falsch meiner meinung nach wir sind es
längst die frage ist mit welcher
dimension wollen wir es sein und um die
welcher dimension entscheidet die usa
entscheidet deutschland scheint die
briten teilzuhaben und mit jeder
lieferung an panzerabwehrwaffen ist die
teilnahme ist die beteiligung intensiver
ist das so frank luger wenn man genauer
hinguckt dass wir eigentlich längst
nicht mehr über einen krieg russland
ukraine sprechen sondern dass dieser
krieg mehr und mehr zu einem
stellvertreterkrieg schon geworden ist
zwischen nato ländern und russland und
nehmen mehr involviert sind ich schaue
mich ein bisschen vor dem begriff
stellvertreterkrieg denn er würde ja
bedeuten dass eine kriegspartei in
diesem fall die ukraine von anfang an
sehr bewusst für die interessen des
westens in dem fall und wir meinen ja
dann in wahrheit die vereinigten staaten
wie instrumentalisiert und eingesetzt
wird das ist ja nicht der fall des wegen
mir ein bisschen probleme mit diesem
begriff dass der westen durch
waffenlieferungen übrigens aber auch
durch militärische aufklärung die wir
glaube ich nicht unterschätzen sollten
die sehr entscheidend ist für die
ukrainische armee dass er in einer putin
definition ja eigentlich längst zum
kriegsteilnehmer zur kriegspartei
geworden ist ist auf der anderen seite
natürlich auch richtig was die russische
strategie betrifft wir wissen ja
wirklich sehr wenig über das was im
kreml gedacht und entschieden wird es
scheint aber offensichtlich so zu sein
dass der neunte mai ein sehr wichtiges
datum für wladimir putin ist der neunte
tag des sieges zweiten weltkriegs und
der russische feiertag patriotisch
pompös aufgeladen und dass er zu diesem
9 mai ein positives ergebnis
vermelden muss möglicherweise ist es an
der taktische shift sich jetzt auf den
don bass zu konzentrieren die befreiung
des don basteln vermeintlichen
faschisten um auch am 9 mai eine sieges
meldung verkünden zu können interessant
darauf kommen wir später wenn wir über
die frage wie es weitergeht noch mal
zurück weil es ein spannender gedanke
ist aber ich möchte zunächst noch einmal
den blick richten auf den nato-gipfel zu
eu und g 7 kommen wir auch noch aber auf
den nato-gipfel am donnerstag
welche signale sind davon ausgegangen
wie sehr sie lenski dazugeschaltet hat
verstärkt um waffenlieferungen auch um
ein prozent der panzer etwa oder der
flugzeuge der nato gebeten und sehr
deutliche forderungen gestellt wie
beurteilen sie die reaktion der nato auf
die aktuelle situation die ergebnisse
dieses nach druck gesetzt naja es gibt
ja zwei große botschaften das eine ist
dieses bild der geschlossenheit der enns
dem hintergrund dieser große gruppe von
staats und regierungschefs die dann
geschlossen steht und auch sich hinter
einer botschaft versammelt die
allerdings auch ihre sollbruchstellen
hat wir haben innerhalb der nato
mitglieder wie ungarn oder wie die
türkei deren rolle alles andere als
eindeutig ist wir haben mitglieder die
fest im westlichen bündnis auch in der
eu verankert sind aber die eben auch
nicht zwingend den kriegen in all seiner
dimension mit begleiten wollen zum
beispiel die südeuropäer italien ist ein
besonders empfindliches land weil die
enorme abhängigkeit vom russischen gas
dort ganz stark gespürt wird das ist das
eine signalen das zweite signal ist
natürlich der mann der angeflogen kam
aus washington amerika übernimmt amerika
führt der präsident steht vorne er sagt
wir geben den takt an ich finde ja
bezeichnet wie der deutsche
bundeskanzler bis in die satz war beiden
imitiert also er übersetzt quasi die
botschaften die beiden auch sagt zum
beispiel mit der flugverbotszone oder
anderen punkten und insofern ist
amerikas rolle in europa nach diesem
donnerstag noch mal sowas von
offensichtlich geworden so fast
unverzichtbar auch geworden und wir
können wirklich froh sein dass wir im
moment eben diesen beiden den weisen aus
haben und niemand anderes der gäste
zusicherung von beiden ja auch wir
werden jeden inch jeden zentimeter des
nato territorium verteidigen das ist
eine zusicherung eine
selbstvergewisserung eine
rückversicherung wie sie glaube ich so
ein bündnis in diesen zeiten noch mal
ganz besonders auch braucht wenn wir
daran denken was noch wenige jahre
vorher passiert waren mit donald trump
und man möchte sich eigentlich gar nicht
so richtig vorstellen was wäre wenn er
noch im weißen haus sitzen würde beiden
als glücksfall in dieser situation
diesem sinne also ich bin auch völlig
d'accord das war wirklich starke
symbolik sehe ich auch so das hat was
vermittelt und dann guckt man aber in
die details und sprachen herrn scholz an
und dann guckt man auf die einzelnen
teile dieser nato und in der tat denkt
man vielleicht brauchte zuletzt übrig
ein paar kampfflugzeuge brauchte
wirklich schwerer kampfpanzer es gibt
viele militärs die sagen dieser
partisanenkrieg der orchestrierte ist
das eine das kann man machen das ist
verlust feucht habe es aber es braucht
auch gegen offensiven wenn sie im
größeren bild was verschieben wollen
müssen sie auch in der lage sein mal
einem russischen verband entgegen zu
treten mit artillerie mit mit panzern
und da ist ja bis jetzt nach meiner
wahrnehmung wenig geliebten und morgen
und microsoft wohl wie sollte man
tatsächlich mehr auch schwereres gerät
darum geht es ja liefern wir driften der
offenbar sonst wirklich in einem sehr
langen abnutzungskrieg der extrem
grausam ist wie mir alle militär leute
erzählen und ich denke ja es geht um
zeit man muss schneller die kosten für
putin erhöhen und dazu bedarf es ja wie
ich glaube auch weitere waffensysteme
auch systeme die etwa groß messer als
abfangen können auch da die steelers
sind das eine aber im augenblick ist das
wetter gut die russischen bomber fliegen
sehr hoch sind nicht mehr erreichbar für
diese diese schulter gestützten stengers
da braucht andere davos buck und was
weis ich bin kein experte jedoch müssten
natürlich bedient werden können das ist
auch seine ausbildung und dann sind wir
schon wieder auf der schiefen ebene da
sind wir eigentlich soldaten entsandt
müssten um diese zu bedienen also das
beste beispiel sind ja die anti schiffs
raketen
wir warten jetzt jeden tag eine andere
operation in odessa eigentlich für
nächste woche von den diensten
vorhergesagt und mit gemeinsam mit einem
nächsten großoffensive auf kiew und die
könnte man abschrecken die könnte man
verhindern wenn man in russland wirst du
an land gibt es diese schiffs
abwehrraketen die natürlich eine
verheerende wirkung entfalten und wir
haben gesehen dass ein schiff das
allerdings bereits angedockt
versenkt wurde beziehungsweise so schwer
beschädigt wurde oder sogar brannten und
das ist das ist natürlich das dilemma
werden eigentlich müsste müsste
tatsächlich sehr lenski jetzt diese
schweren waffen
auch bedienen können oder leute haben
die das tun vielleicht gibt das die auch
zum teil aber auch sie allein zu
transportieren haben wir gesehen wie
schwer sich die amerikaner getan haben
vor allem mit der überstellung der mit
kampfflugzeuge aus polen warum ist das
so weil die jetzt wirklich keinen großen
unterschied machen aber die von ihnen
genannten waffen die wäre natürlich
tatsächlich
nicht kriegsentscheidend aber würden
massiv das kriegsgeschehen war das
scheint mir aber im hinterkopf auch da
zu sein das ist nicht nur die erkenntnis
ist es technisch schwer umzusetzen da
ist doch immer glaube ich im hinterkopf
der der gedanke wir wollen jetzt nicht
zuviel provozieren dass das ist meine
wahl nicht warum ich will dass sie auch
in berlin zum beispiel eine wichtige
rolle spielt wir wollen jetzt nicht zu
deutlich werden unserer hilfe um dann
keine falsche reaktionen auch laube war
schlicht die sorge besteht vor der
eskalation dominanz des russischen
präsidenten
die militäroperationen vor allen dingen
durch angriffe aus der luft und mein
massiv im
auszuweiten
möglicherweise chemische waffen
einzusetzen vom einsatztaktische
atomraketen wollen wir gar nicht
sprechen aber die rhetorik ist ja da und
ich glaube führt für das westliche
bündnis für den westen ist es das
dilemma und zugleich sind die sehr
delikate frage die balance zu halten
zwischen
unterstützung für die ukraine zwischen
auch der möglichkeit sanktionen und
militär was machen lieferungen weiter zu
erhöhen je nachkriegs verlauf und
dennoch am klar zu machen die nato wird
keinen krieg um die ukraine führen ja
also ich dazu getan das ist eine frage
die würde ich gern ein sie geben mir nur
war da habe ich einen interessanten
eintrag im netz gefunden und das wird ja
auch politisch diskutiert peter hansen
heckel fragt auf twitter warum geben die
usa und die nato immer noch bekannt nie
in den krieg eingreifen zu wollen das
ist doch nichts anderes als eine
einladung für putin und seine militärs
immer weiter zu gehen keiner hält ihn
richtig auf also die frage auch wenn man
es gar nicht will es ist klug es so
deutlich zu sagen oder wäre es
vielleicht taktisch nicht klüger putin
im ungewissen zu lassen
die usa und die nato
versuchen
diese eskalation zu vermeiden weil sie
weil weil es ein bewusstes wie hoch die
risiken von einem krieg zwischen nato
und russland sind deshalb versuchen
vermeiden sie das auch kommunikativ das
verfolgen sie weiter die strategie
jetzt waffenlieferungen und mit
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen druck auf
gut hin zu erhöhen und bereits jetzt
werden auch die wirtschaftlichen
sanktionen als
totale krieg des westens gegen russland
interpretiert die propaganda die nach
innen gerichtet wird interpretiert das
als existenzkampf russlands zum beispiel
der ehemalige kulturminister wo er die
mail mit jungs kiel der die russische
delegation bei den verhandlungen in der
ukraine anführt sagte vor einigen tagen
das gehe auf dem spiel stehe die
existenz russlands als zivilisation das
heißt noch mehr druck
also ich das produkt wenn die nato
deutlich macht dass sie auf keinen fall
involviert sein wie direkt in dieser
kriegerische auseinandersetzung
das kommt auch auf den verlauf dieses
krieges an weil bereits jetzt ist das
eine beispiellose humanitäre krise die
tausenden menschen die gestorben sind
millionen menschen sind geflüchtet und
die länge dieser krieg dauert
desto wahrscheinlicher stellt sich die
frage ob die wirtschaftssanktionen
ausreichen oder ob sie westen nicht rote
linien ziehen muss zum beispiel beim
einsatz von gehe ich schon mal von ohne
biologische waffen nehmen wir das mal
gutes stichwort es ist ja etwas was
durchaus im raum steht was diskutiert
wird die nächste stufe der eskalation
könnte der einsatz von abc-waffen sein
wie wahrscheinlich ist dass ich halte es
für wahrscheinlich dass putin
unkontrolliert reagiert wenn er in einer
für sich empfunden ausweglosen
ausweglosen situationen sich empfindet
die nächste steigerung möglichkeit ist
immer noch konventionell das heißt er
hat schon noch truppen es gibt diese
gruppierung seine einheiten wir sehen
diesen versuch kiew zu einzukesseln
einzukreisen möglicherweise auch zu
blockieren das ist die nächste stufe
aber was passiert danach was passiert in
zwei drei wochen und dann bleibt
eigentlich nur noch eskalation hin zu
den anderen zu diesen
massenvernichtungswaffen warum würde er
das tun nicht um sie möglicherweise
sogar einzusetzen weil es werden ja auch
seine eigenen soldaten im schussfeld
sondern um ein signal des schocks zu
senden um uns wirklich so
in einen angst zustand zu versetzen dass
aus dieser situation heraus
möglicherweise gar eine kapitulation
erfolgt die russischen streitkräfte
haben das geübt wir wissen dass von den
vielen nuklearer übungen der letzten
jahre zahlen sich 19 bei einer der ganz
entscheidenden das taktische atomwaffen
also die sogenannten kleinen atomwaffen
tut mir leid was jetzt war eine
militärische sprache ist aber das ist
nun mal die unterscheidung sind
verheerend genug dass diese taktischen
atomwaffen eingesetzt werden quasi als
show of force als zeichen der stärke
über der barentssee also ich war
russischem territorium da können wir
sagen ja gut dann sollen sie über ihren
territorien der nuklear fraktion geht
uns ja nichts an ich glaube das ist
nicht so das wäre das erste mal seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg dass diese waffe in
einem krieg eingesetzt würde auch zur
demonstration von macht es wäre ein
geist aus der flasche es wäre ein
unvorstellbares szenario auch weltweit
ein signal an möchtegern atommächte an
starten die auch mit diesem gedanken
spielen nordkorea zum beispiel pakistan
indien die spannung sind hoch iran
strebt danach die saudis streben danach
ägypten strebt danach also das wird eine
andere welt und insofern ist das was sie
eben sagten diese signaling was sagt man
wie weit geht man ist man teil des
krieges oder nicht dieses diesen
botschaften sind enorm wichtig deswegen
kurzer sprung zurück zum gipfel was
beiden sagte war bemerkenswert er sagte
er mehr reagieren wir werden die den
einsatz von biologischen und chemischen
waffen nicht unbeantwortet lassen er hat
die atomaren waffen ausgelassen das
stellt den kreml vor rätsel die werden
jetzt tagelang darüber diskutieren was
das bedeutet aber das ist gut diese
diese art schwammigkeit dieser dieser
grauzone die muss erzeugt werden auch im
erkrankungs grünen aus abschreckungs
gründen aber es ist wirklich ganz klar
dass diese bombe nicht dazu werden darf
in den leitlinien frau lokal wie putin
fürs militär erlassen hat gibt es den
hinweis wenn truppen auf andere art
einen krieg nicht gewinnen können dürfen
sie atomwaffen einsetzen das ist
offenbar teil der russischen strategie
der nationalen sicherheit
eskaliert ubs kalt heißt das in diesem
militär englisch also in dem moment in
dem die existenz des russischen staates
sowie der ehemalige kulturminister ist
ja schon formuliert hat die existenz des
russischen staates auf dem spiel steht
in einem konventionellen krieg
könne russland atomwaffen sprich
taktische atomwaffen einsetzen
um die konventionelle übermacht eines
gegners zu brechen und dann in
verhandlungen zu gehen das scheint so zu
sein
wir lesen aus washington aber auch aus
paris und berlin dass man ja sehr wohl
die sorge davor hat vor einem russischen
präsidenten der sich immer weiter in die
enge getrieben fühlt und irgendwann gar
nicht mehr weiß wie reagieren sollen ich
glaube deswegen versucht man auch wenn
diese feine balance in diesem
furchtbaren dilemma man muss die ukraine
unterstützen die ukraine darf den krieg
nicht verlieren und putin darf diesen
krieg nicht gewinnen
diese balance waren auch
rhetorisch um die möglicherweise
ein eine tür zu einer exit-strategie zu
öffnen denn ich glaube man muss davon
ausgehen dass man mit ihm auch
verhandeln müssen wird
[Musik]
beim einsatz von chemie und biowaffen
hat der nato-generalsekretär gesagt
würde es schwere konsequenzen geben was
heißt denn das was würde passieren
gute frage denn was wir jetzt schon als
verhängten wirtschaftssanktionen sehen
die tun mittelfristig und langfristig
sicherlich sehr sehr wenigen russland
extrem schade aber das kann putin sich
erstmal
zumuten seiner bevölkerung hat ja keine
demokratische bevölkerung die ihn dann
in drei wochen aufmuckt das so ist der
deckel der repression viel zu fest auf
dem topf er kann das schon eine ganze
weile machen im augenblick ist er in
genau dieser problematik muss irgendwas
zeigen und der neuen thema ist glaube
ich wirklich ein datum wo er dass das
irgendwie zusammen basteln muss daher
ist diese die diese idee man wolle jetzt
sich auf die konsolidierung des donbass
beschränken alle die etwas hoffnung in
mir ausgelöst hat
ich weiß nur dass eine frau in der
wirtschaft aber wie so viele botschaften
weiß natürlich auch nicht fehlen darf
keine antarktischen dazu sagt dass wir
natürlich eine wirklich erst mal gute
lösung wenn man sich auf dieses gebiet
konzentriert dass das hat kfw schon so
ein bisschen
halb abgeschrieben zumindest die
besetzten gebiete das wäre ein weg aber
es wird auf jeden fall zu einem
irgendwie garten sehr schmutzigen
kompromiss kommen wir werden irgendwann
erleben wie min 2 wo unter dem massiven
militärischen druck ein kompromiss
irgendwie zusammen gebastelt wird der
der keiner weise zufrieden macht der
auch wahrscheinlich absehbar keinen
bestand hat aber erstmal so etwas
erwarte ich irgendwo das ist anlass
musste der russen die die anfrage ist ja
schon wie kann man das abschrecken also
wie kann man verhindern dass es so
schmutzig wird und das ist glaube ich
das motto wer sich jetzt alle mal ganz
kräftig den kopf zerbrechen müssen haben
sie an und natürlich es gibt es kein
raus damit
das ist immer die gefahr dass man wenn
man über abschreckung redet besonders in
diesem land kommt gleich die keule mit
dem kriegstreiber und so und ganz
ehrlich es ist sehr sehr schwierig aber
es fehlt hierzulande so ein bisschen die
die bereitschaft sich auch in dieser
harte auseinandersetzung hineinzubegeben
um zu verhindern dass das passiert das
muss das ziel von abschreckung sein und
dieses denken abschreckungs kategorien
das ist uns ein stück weit verloren
gegangen aber es glaube ich jetzt wieder
zwingend nötig natürlich gibt es
militärische möglichkeiten auf den 11
erwehren zum beispiel kann man die
stellung die einer chemie war für
abgeschossen hat beschießen man kann zb
die russische satelliten navigation
ausschalten man kann verschiedene andere
dinge tun also es gibt möglichkeiten
ohne großes länder einzusetzen
selbstverständlich also da wird alles 20
liefern oder ist ja also ich bin
wirklichkeit kein
militär sagen ist mehr als es wirklich
ist auf eine nuklear anschlag wird man
nicht mit einem nuklear schlag antworten
das ist ja auch töricht also diese
eskalationsgefahr die ist ja unglaublich
gefährlich aber das ist permanente
kalibrieren zwischen abschreckung und
vermeidung einer eskalation das ist die
größte kunst momentan als beiden zb
gestern abend sagte mein gott mit diesem
mann geht es nicht mehr haben wir alles
sofort interpretiert beiden ruf zum
sturz von putin auf nein er hat nur
gesagt was wir alle hier reden mit putin
geht es nicht mehr aber trotzdem die
botschaft ist auch an die russische
elite stark wir sehen auch dass das
nicht mehr geht natürlich hat das weiße
haus das gleich zurück geholt ich glaube
nicht dass es ein versprecher war ich
glaube es war bewusst gesetzt um bewusst
wieder zurückgeholt aber die botschaft
dass in der welt und an dem müssen wir
uns jetzt abarbeiten geht es mit putin
noch auf die komme ich nochmal zurück
aber wir müssen liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen einer über gas öl und kohle
kohle weniger aber gas und öl
reden wo europa insbesondere deutschland
massiv abhängig ist und das war ein
mittelpunkt thema des eu gipfels auch
beim g 7 aber vor allen dingen beim
eu-gipfel frau zu mir noch in sachen
wirtschaftssanktionen
insbesondere auch in der frage
sehr sehr viel geld das wir zahlen an
russland für putins krieg auch gibt es
da ergebnisse dieser gipfel begegnung wo
sie sagen das ist vernünftig oder sind
sie unzufrieden
ich glaube dass die dass die einigkeit
auch in den letzten wochen von der eu
und vom g7 was die wirtschafts- und
jungen geht tatsächlich sehr wichtig war
und dass diese einigkeit und kriege
überrascht hat die russische regierung
steht bereits stark unter druck mit
wirtschaftssanktionen aber gleichzeitig
versucht der kreml energieimporte als
druckmittel zu nutzen um einen keil
zwischen engländern zu treiben und dabei
ist das denken von putin von seinen
erfahrungen aus den letzten jahren
beeinflusst hat nach der kommunikation
nach dem beginn des krieges in der ost
ukraine nach dem brand in syrien konnte
russland war ich in lukrativer
gasgeschäft in deutschland schließen
deshalb ist das kalkül des kremls dass
man es weiterhin auch tun kann und dass
die importstopp
dass kein importstopp von von öl und gas
geben wird und klar ein kompletter
baustopp sofort wäre auch für die eu
sehr schmerzhaft dass man muss sich eine
realistische lösung ausdenken aber ich
hätte vielleicht keine perfekte lösung
auf die man noch zwei jahre lang warten
soll es kann nicht sein dass putin
ukrainische städte angreift und
gleichzeitig gas nach deutschland
geliefert und dabei noch bedingungen
diktiert sommer 24 brauchen wir
russisches gas hat der wirtschafts und
klimaschutzminister gerade verkündet na
jedenfalls andere die fatale
entscheidung für nord stream zwei die
haben wir viel zu spät aber die haben
wir dann einmal rückgängig gemacht
immerhin
dies
jeder weiß dass ein sofortiger stopp der
öl- und gasimporte wirtschaftlich enorme
folgen für europa und auch für
deutschland hätte
verschiedene szenarien kleinere
rezession mittlere rezession große
rezession
das würde man dann sehen wie weit wir
wirklich ging aber die wirtschaftlichen
folgen wären schnell und sie wären groß
und ich finde wir müssen darum eine
offene eine klare und eine ernsthafte
debatte auch führen als gesellschaft
sind wir bereit im zweifel solche folgen
auch zu tragen und auch auszuhalten auch
über längere zeit denn wir müssen
sanktionen immer länger aushalten können
als derjenige in dem fall derjenige
putin dem diese sanktionen gelten
und man kann ja auch über so etwas wie
einen konditionierten
importstopp ein konto zahlen diesen
rückhalt zum beispiel an wir setzen aus
überweisen in euro nicht in rubel wir
überweisen in euro auf ein konto und
wenn es zu einem dauerhaften
waffenstillstand
zb kommt als ersten großen schritt dann
können wir neue reden ich weiß es sind
alles hilfskonstruktionen das alles
liest was in moskau eindruck schinden
würde wenn man sagen würde okay wir
setzen aus solange die waffen donnern
bei waffenstillstand machen wir wieder
geschäfte so zwei dinge dazu ich bin
nicht experte genug um die wirklichen
auswirkungen eines solchen importstopps
zu beurteilen wie dramatisch unserer
industrie dann in die knie gehen weiß
ich nicht ich glaube eigentlich es wäre
abzufedern weil alles ist auf dieser
welt eine frage des preises und wir sind
kein armes land ich glaube wir würden
noch halbwegs damit umgehen können aber
ich weiß es nicht was ich interessant
fand ist dieser hinweis auf die
russischen eliten dass das signal beiden
an die eliten ging er hat niedrige murat
auf gerade ein sehr spannender artikel
geschrieben und der ist er nicht so vor
die stimmen und der hat keine hoffnung
darauf er sagt die eliten um putin rum
sind quasi 100 hinter ihm diesen auch
gefangen in dieser
großen visionen wir müssen das ding
jetzt die wogen in der ukraine da
spaltkeil reinzukriegen über solche
signale hält glaube ich morath
vernichten richtig gelesen habe für für
sehr unwahrscheinlich glaube putin ist
in einer sehr viel bringen
extremsituation er weiß was ihm droht
also er muss auch liefern sondern macht
system ist wirklich gefährdet durch das
wasser passiert und alles was
mittelfristige finanzprobleme angeht das
wischt der blick vom tisch auf der
schiene denkt überhaupt nicht bei adata
land jahr 20 jahre zielstrebig
wirtschaftlich ruiniert es gab mal ein
toller artikel der new york times ist
putin
existenziell man einfach mal ironischen
titel wenn das eigene land systematisch
sein eigenes land ökonomisch ruiniert
und wirtschaft ist ihm schon seit vielen
jahren wurde lebt in seiner historischen
welt der bilder die das gros russische
reich wiederherstellen könnte es mir nur
dass wir die frage öl- und gas-embargo
gar nicht mehr lange diskutieren müssen
ab montag hat putin angeordnet müssen
wir in rubel zahlen
die abnehmer haben klar gemacht das
machen sie nicht in den verträgen sind
dollar oder euro vorgesehen kannst du
das gewesen sein und gut ihn dreht
einfach den gas und öl hallen zu in den
nächsten tagen mussten bis uns nicht die
manager von gazprom
er ist technisch und logistisch italien
das herausarbeiten das heißt die müssen
die tatsächlich die entweder die
verträge überarbeiten was kann ich so
einfach ist aber
russland ist auch von gasexporten
abhängige ist das ist eher als drohung
zu verstehen
dieser schritt wobei der anteil am
budget nicht so groß ist das öl gläubig
der deutlich größere batzen entfällt
eine chance ich meine band öl deswegen
sehr dafür differenzierter darauf zu
gucken wie katja gloger das eben auch
gesagt hat die die die ölabhängigkeit
lässt sich ausgleichen das sagen
inzwischen sämtliche berechnungen auch
der bundesregierung vielleicht sogar
gekoppelt mit ein paar
lieblingsprojekten der grünen in der
bundesregierung im jahr an tempolimits
ich glaube die bereitschaft der
öffentlichkeit wäre enorm mal vielleicht
100 auf der autobahn zu fahren wenn man
weiß da tut man auch und ist nicht nur
für die umwelt sondern ob man stoppt
vielleicht auch mal hilft diesen krieg
zu stoppen das zweite ist gas wer sagt
denn dass russland überhaupt die
gaslieferung so schnell stoppen kann es
kommt aus 6000 gasquellen geströmt das
muss man erst mal schließen technisch
das ist gar nicht so einfach
diese pipelines sind vielleicht nicht zu
gebrauchen wenn sie leer sind also es
gibt ganz viele fragen die auch im
russischen interesse genutzt werden
können wo man den spieß mal umdreht und
mir fehlt so ein bisschen auch hier
wieder die bereitschaft unkonventionell
zu denken vielleicht ein bisschen nach
vorne zu gehen auch zu gucken wo man für
sich einen vorteil hat die idee mit den
treuhandkonten die ist schon länger als
auf dem markt warum macht man das nicht
mehr also es gibt dann sicher die
hoffnung man erreichte durch die eliten
ich habe wirklich keine kenntnis was in
der russischen führung vorgeht und ob
man dort menschen beeinflussen kann aber
wir werden doch das teufels wenn man es
nicht versuchte das würde ich gern
aufgreifen und noch mal in die runde
gegeben nämlich was bewirkt es wie man
sie alle gerichtet wirken derzeit die
sanktion in russland wie sehr
beeindrucken sie putin in seinem
weiteren handeln und wie fest sitzt ja
eigentlich selber noch im sattel oder
gibt es auch dazu gibt es immer wieder
meldungen bereits
absetzbewegungen auch in den eigenen
reihen der russischen in herrlich
schwerer schwierige frage weil dazu
brauchen die meinungsumfragen wenn sie
es wirklich objektivieren wollen und das
ist ein schwieriges geschäft heutzutage
werden telefonisch gemacht die leute
haben wirklich große große angst also
das ist er zudem ganz dicken daumen und
und meine eindrücke sind eher
anekdotisch natur und da bin ich schon
überrascht wie häufig ich von kontakten
höhere zustimmung zu dem putin ding auch
die bereitschaft opfer zu ertragen das
hat er ja seit vielen vielen jahren
vorbereitet mit dieser anthologie zum
zweiten weltkrieg am ende stand zwar der
glorreiche sieg über den faschismus der
weg dahin war aber unfassbar opfer reich
und und schwierig aber wir müssen es
durchhalten am ende klappt dann dieses
grundgefühl hatte so nachhaltig in
seiner bevölkerung hinein transportiert
per propagandamaschine
dass viele dass das inzwischen
geschluckt haben unser ok das beiden
blöde zeiten kein iphone mehr und und
das wird knapp und da gibt es leere
regale im supermarkt aber das ist der
böse besten der auf die knie zwingen
will das werden wir nicht zulassen wir
werden durchhalten das hat er sehr
geschickt geschafft stefan geier fragt
auf twitter was kann putin eigentlich
stoppen argumente oder weitere
operationen oder eben auch oligarchen
oder eliten aus den eigenen reihen frau
aus mir noch gibt so etwas wie ein
turning point an dem man sagt wenn das
und das geschehen ist dann ist eine lage
da an der ernsthafte verhandlungen über
einen frieden in der ukraine mit
russland möglich sind
also was die was die eliten dann gehts
dann waren wir in den restlichen gesehen
dass der kreis den entscheidungen
getroffen werden immer kleiner wurde und
putin es gibt immer weniger menschen die
einfluss auf ihn haben und die ihm zu
solchen verhandlungen bewegen können
auch die
wirtschaftsleute
haben keinen großen einfluss auf die
strategie um die verhandlungen sondern
die ihnen wird es überlassen die den
schaden zu minimieren und auch die
wahrscheinlichkeit von massenprotesten
halte ich für sehr gering dazu
hat der staat tatsächlich mit hilfe von
repressionen auf der einen seite und
propaganda auf der anderen seite
doch die gesellschaft fest im griff und
die eu fragen sind mit vorsicht zu
genießen in repression starten aber es
sieht so aus dass ein großer teil
die bevölkerung diesen krieg und putin
unterstützt und da sind vor allem
menschen über 50 45 die ehrenformation
aus dem staatsmedien beziehungen die
jungen menschen wiederum sind eher gegen
diesen krieg dann können auch wir ganz
am ende der sendung deswegen bitte ganz
kurze antwort der druck den wir jetzt
auslösen macht der eine was handlungs
lösung wahrscheinlicher oder könnte auch
kontraproduktiv wirken ich glaube wir
bleiben in dem dilemma stecken die
ukraine darf den krieg nicht verlieren
kiew darf nicht fallen um in diesem bild
zu bleiben
putin darf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
und mit diesem dilemma werden wir leben
müssen das war ihr schluss verordnen wir
sind am ende der sendung angelangt danke
für die engagierte diskussion dass liebe
zuschauer war der presseclub im ersten
wir freuen uns wenn sie in den sozialen
netzwerken weiter mit uns diskutieren
mögen etwa beim presseclub account oft
mit da hier geht's jetzt weiter mit dem
europamagazin und auch da geht es
monothematisch um die lage in der
ukraine
dann gibt s da heute noch eine
landtagswahl im saarland nämlich und wir
berichten live ab 17.45 hier im ersten
den presseclub nachgefragt den gibt es
jetzt wie immer auf phoenix und im radio
auf wdr5 ich danke für ihr interesse und
wir alle hier wünschen ihnen noch einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]
willkommen zurück ich begrüße sie zum
presseclub nachgefragt hier auf phoenix
und im radio auf wdr5 mehr geld mehr
waffen mehr soldaten was stoppt putin
das ist das thema unserer runde heute
ihr im presseclub jetzt sind sie dran
mit ihren fragen an meine gäste und ich
gehe zunächst nach kassel dort ist
dort ist detlef meinecke am telefon
nummern hört im hintergrund dass er den
presseclub verfolgt das freut uns und
jetzt haben einige sind sie dran mit
ihrer frage an unsere runde
ja guten tag meine damen und herren
groß in die runde ich habe mich im
ersten teil der sendung total
erschrocken
da hatte ich das gefühl ich bin hier auf
ein militär seminar wo es darum geht
welche sachen am besten helfen sollten
es wurde in der saison zugegeben dass
die nato durch ihre hilfsleistungen
werks längst in den krieg verwickelt ist
und dann noch weiter zu reden mich
denken was und mit welchen besseren
waffen man helfen könnte finde ich
ausgesprochen gefährlich und nicht dem
anspruch gerecht 15 in der sexuelle
vertreten sich gedanken über die
beendigung des krieges zu machen und
nicht darüber
was was da was passieren soll putin muss
die gelegenheit gegeben werden
aus der situation halt des gesichts
wahrend
herauszukommen und darum ist muss auch
auf höchster ebene und damit meine ich
auch die amerikaner mit ihm geregelt
werden punkt das töten muss aufhören
danke herr meinecke für diesen beitrag
und den gebe ich gern an meinen kollegen
stefan kornelius weil ja das ist ein
sehr typischer beitragen ich bin dankbar
dass sie angerufen haben und das ist
auch so geäußert haben gleichzeitig
erlaube ich mir die gegenfrage wie soll
das bitte geschehen es gab ja wirklich
keinen mangel an gesprächs versuchen mit
putin
auch beiden der in selbst im letzten
jahr getroffen hat auf der
außenministerebene
aus europa der der französische
präsident der besonders engagiert ist
der fast jetzt noch zwei drei mal die
woche mit ihm telefoniert nur politisch
bewegt sich nichts und entschuldigungen
dass wir über die waffen reden aber da
ist ein krieg und der wird gerade mit
waffen geführt mir wäre auch lieber
würde nicht geführt oder die bewaffnung
wäre so ausgeglichen dass die einsicht
da wäre dass sie nicht geführt werden
muss und nun ist die aggression relativ
eindeutig zuzuordnen nicht nur relativ
sondern sie ist eindeutig zuzuordnen und
deswegen ich verstehe unbehagen ich
glaube auch dass sehr viele das teilen
ich teile das auch aber
ich glaube wir werden in diesem krieg
leider leider noch sehr viele
schreckliche dinge sehen bis ein punkt
erreicht ist so ein was sozusagen ein
politischer kipp punkt auch kommt wir
haben vorhin darüber gesprochen was muss
geschehen damit es so weit kommt dass
man rede dass man verhandelt wir sehen
es noch nicht es wird ein militärische
situation sein es wird eine
innenpolitische in russland seien durch
die eliten es wird vielleicht
tatsächlich dann auch der fall von kiew
sein und eine kapitulation wir wissen
erst momentan nicht aber dass man sagt
ja wir sind alle für frieden das sind
wir alle nur da kommen wir nicht hin
wenn man es nur proklamieren
dankeschön in oranienburg begrüße ich
diese la plänen am telefon frau pläne
herzlich willkommen in unserer runde und
los geht's
meine frage wäre es wurde der ukraine
eine sicherheitsgarantie geben von den
engländern und den amerikanern und jetzt
diskutieren wir dass wir keine waffen
geben durften so eine chance hätten die
engländer und amerikaner zu meinem
vorredner jetzt schon längst eingreifen
müssen putin hatte doch unterschrieben
nicht und der kalli verändert
jetzt sind sie uns abhanden gekommen
aber frau plänen ihre frage ist
angekommen es geht um das budapester
abkommen ja da sprechen sie sprechen
auf die budapester übereinkunft
sprechen sie ihn vor vielen jahren
unterzeichnet immer wieder ein klein
bisschen falsch dargestellt falsch
interpretiert nämlich dass drei mächte
großbritannien die vereinigten staaten
und russland dass sie haben dann die
garantie mächte irgendwie sein um den
abzug der nuklearwaffen aus der ukraine
zu begleiten und die souveränität der
ukraine zu garantieren das war in diesem
abkommen leider nicht so eine garantie
wurde nie ausgesprochen sondern
lediglich eine zusicherung an die sich
in wahrheit sobald die atomwaffen aus
der ukraine abgezogen waren niemand mehr
hält
und wenn wir heute den ukrainischen
präsidenten syriens gehören der ja sehr
wohl signale sendet wie könnten mögliche
punkte für eine verhandlung der ukraine
mit putin denn die ukraine verhandeln
mit putin haben wir aussehen dann
spricht er ja darauf an möglicherweise
keine nato mitgliedschaft der ukraine
aber echte harte sicherheitsgarantien
sowohl des westens als auch von moskau
weiter geht es mit einem zuschauer aus
der hansestadt hamburg rainer corning
ist an telefon herning seien sie gegrüßt
jede fragestellung lautet ja was doch
mehr machen ihr geld ich finde die
fragestellungen interessant was beendet
den krieg also ich hatte in den letzten
wochen
informationen gelesen gehört im radio
usw dass es wohl die forderung von buden
gibt nach der unabhängig anerkennen der
unabhängigkeit des tom barth sowie der
neutralität der ukraine sowie die
anerkennung 6 im als russisches
staatsgebiet und ich habe nun in der
letzten woche gelesen dass herr
bielawski
möglicherweise auf die forderung
eingehen will einher gehen mit einer
veränderung an seine bevölkerung warum
geht es in viele richtungen ich werde
möglicherweise eine einigung geben
könnte danke schön herr corning pfosten
aber was stoppt den krieg wie könnte die
einigung der corning anspricht aussehen
die entscheidung darüber wie die
einigung aussehen wird ist vor allem die
ukrainische entscheidung weil die
ukraine wurde verfolgen die ukraine
verhandelt mit russlands das politische
ziel dass putin versuchen wir diesen
krieg zu erreichen ist starke
einschränkungen der ukrainisch und
souveränität und das war von anfang an
kaum realistisch weil sehr viele
menschen in die ukraine das nicht
hinnehmen würden sie würden auch jeden
präsidenten abwägenden gegen jeden
präsidenten protestieren der
ukrainische souveränität an putin
abtritt und das muss man
das muss man immer im auge behalten und
auch münchen hat damit aber ein fehler
gemacht er hat nicht an die menschen in
die ukraine gedacht und ich glaube jede
westliche politiker der versuchen oder
ukraine zu einem kompromiss zu drängen
würde den gleichen fehler machen das ist
für ihre entscheidung die bevölkerung
ist anders wünscht
ich glaube es wichtig noch ist ja sagen
ist dass die details dieser vereinbarung
der tatsächlich verhandelt ist noch sehr
recht also der diese verhandlungsgruppen
der papiere geschrieben dass wie bei so
einem gipfeldokument in klammern was
unbestritten unbestritten und
unbestritten ist in jeder professionelle
verhandler gesagt dass kriege ich in 12
tagen sozusagen vom tisch aber es gibt
an der spitze den politischen willen
nicht weil die bedingungen mit
souveränitätsverzicht mit einer quasi
aufgabe jeder eigen staatlichen merkmal
der eigentlichen merkmale so stark sind
dass das weder von der ukraine
akzeptiert wird noch vor ostern auf der
anderen seite akzeptiert wird das ist
unterhalb dieser kompletten unterwerfung
eine andere option noch gibt und
insofern ist das noch zu weit
auseinander
die nächste hansestadt kommt dran bremen
olaf brandstätter dann seien sie gegrüßt
herbrand
hinaus streben in die wunde ein kurzes
statement also ich bemerke in der
diskussion nicht nur hier so zum
beispiel klaus von dohnanyi brachte mal
rein er würde den erst mal zehn jahre
neutralität irgendwie auf den tisch
legen und so weiter und dann gibt es
manchmal so gegenreden die sagen ja sie
bedienen sehr schnell das russische
narrativ also mein statement ist ich
gehe bei dieser ganzen zeitenwende logik
die uns der agrarpolitik aufzwingt da
nicht so schnell mit meine frage wäre ob
wenn ich mal solche bilder wie wir sie
jetzt in brüssel gesehen haben als so
eine art mini demo vor dem kreml von von
hochrangigen eu leuten haben könnten ist
das realistisch oder dass er naiv so was
sich vorzustellen dass die leute dort
wirklich mal dort flagge zeigen hochlage
große gruppen von europäern hochrangige
regierungsbeamte
danke herr brandstätter
keine frage ist verboten man muss alles
fragen dürfen aber es ist für meinen
geschmack recht weit entfernt von von
der realität ich glaube das würde nicht
mut nicht möglich gemacht werden von
putin und seiner umgebung dass da eine
symbolträchtige europäische demo vor dem
kreml stattfindet das wird man zu
verhindern wissen wir können sie schon
getroffen der us general
wir ja die symbole
eines eine aufrechterhaltung des
kontakts zu die mir putin und wenn mark
rohr oder scholz beiden macht es im
moment nicht aus guten gründen tut er
das nicht mensch holz oder makro
vergleichsweise regelmäßig mit putin
telefonieren die werden ja nicht nur nur
in anführungszeichen darüber sprechen
dass putin irrt sofort um seine truppen
aus der ukraine haben wie abziehen soll
sondern sie werden versuchen zu eruieren
gibt es möglichkeiten für
verhandlungen und das werden sie tun
dann im einverständnis mit
der ukrainischen führung
stichwort neutralität
auf soundsoviel jahre zumindest keine
mitgliedschaft in der nato und
stichwort john bass
gebiete im osten der ukraine
von dem putin nicht lassen wird weil es
ein teil seiner legitimation ist ein
ganz wesentlicher teil seiner
politischen legitimation auch für diesen
krieg und die frage ist welche
kompromissbereitschaft am so furchtbar
das klingt welche kompromissbereitschaft
es auf ukrainischer seite für diese
gebiete gibt
größer als nächste anruferin ariane
müller frau müller willkommen in unserer
runde und ihre anmerkung
in die runde
was der herr cornelius gesagt hat mir
sehr gut gefallen auch der vorredner aus
kassel dem stimme ich auch zu meine
frage ist druck erzeugt gewissermaßen
auch gegen druck und herr putin wird auf
jeden fall nicht aufgeben nicht ganz
sicher bis er die radtour atomraketen
gestartet und ich bin auch der meinung
dass nicht nur putin der aggressor ist
sondern auch die usa sie halten es zwar
immer raus und sagen sie machen nichts
und wollen nicht eingreifen aber
indirekt machen sie es doch in dem wald
holen an uns gas und öl verkaufen und
nicht wollen dass die russen praktisch
an rohöl und gas verkaufen und deshalb
ist die nord dem zwei ja auch gestoppt
worden und wie gesagt wie gesagt druck
erzeugt gegendruck und putin ist mit nur
druck und noch mehr sanktionen nicht
aufzuhalten das ist mein statement und
meine frage wozu nachwahl zum
verständnis welchen druck hat der westen
dann erzeugt und putin jetzt zudem zu
motivieren was er getan hat
frau müller aber ja durch die ganzen
sanktionen die immer mehr werden immer
mehr wären und es letztendlich ja nicht
springen und er wird bis zum das letzte
messer und blut wird er kämpfen das ist
leider so ruhig gehen aktion hätten wir
keine sanktionen verhängen sollen um ihn
nicht zu provozieren
januar die ukraine hat immer quatsch die
creme hat immer zu russland gehört
jahren war immer so aus der geschichte
heraus
und wie gesagt putin wird nämlich
aufgeben und seit 2014 sind da wenn
immer mehr sanktionen verhängt und immer
mehr druck ausgeübt vom westen an putin
und das wird in die hose gehen ganz
definitiv bis wir einen atomkrieg
bekommen
definieren will allerdings möchten ja
das ist die logik die auch unser
beliebter philosoph precht vertritt
letztlich die ukraine sollen aufhören zu
kämpfen
das bedeutet nur weitere opfer besser
ist die unterwerfung um das ganze
schnell vom tisch zu kriegen nicht mal
wenn du das mal zu ende denken wo kommen
wir denn hin gutem weg seine ziele immer
weiter verfolgen damit immer weiter
eskalieren in
alle möglichen richtungen wenn sie nicht
sagen jetzt ist aber genug dann geht es
weiter ich meine das ist ja die die
selbstaufgabe so wollen dann würde ich
gern noch einmal nach saarbrücken zu
sascha dietrich gehen dietrich seien sie
gegrüßt und sie haben eine interessante
anmerkung zu unserer diskussion und
tragen ihre meine frage wäre wie wollen
wir mit russland in zukunft umgehen
deutschland wird ja nach wie vor unter
nachbarn bleiben und ich vertrage karte
verschwinden und es wird auch ein tut
hin irgendwann mal nicht mehr da sein
die wollen wir mit russland in zukunft
umgehen
herr cornelius das ist wirklich die
schwierigste aller fragen weil sie so
weit in die zukunft weist und szenarien
andeutet dass wir heute nicht
beantworten können russland ist eine
geografische tatsache ganz banal zu
sagen dass plant bleibt unser nachbar es
ist bleibt auch hoffentlich irgendwie
ein guter nachbar oder wird ein guter
nachbar aber die schlüsselfrage um auch
den kreis zu frau müller zu ziehen die
vorher angerufen hatte ist doch
wie kann dieses zusammenleben wie kann
diese kooperation wie kann dieses
verständnis funktionieren momentan ist
doch alles zurückzuführen auf diesen
ganz großen ideologischen clash denn wir
haben die die die furcht putins vor
einer freien demokratischen welt von
einer gesellschaft die selbst bestimmt
von leuten die auf die straße gehen die
die freie medien lesen wollen die neue
partei gründen wollen die vielleicht
auch mein regierungschef abwählen wollen
und das verträgt sich nicht mit seinem
staatsverständnis und deswegen erleben
wir nicht erst seit diesem krieg sondern
seit 20 jahren seitdem putin an der
macht ist immer wieder die ideologischen
konflikt und wo kann man sagen da kann
die eine sanktion und dann kam die
andere sache geschichte ist nie
monokausal es geschieht die aus einem
ereignis heraus nicht die
nato-erweiterung war die ursache von
allen nein das ist ein spiel von allen
day sein herr cornelius ich so liebe ich
unterbreche aber willkommen zum ende ist
denn eine rückkehr egal wie es jetzt in
der ukraine am ende aussieht zu einer
irgendwie gearteten normalität mit putin
denkbar mit putin halte ich das für sehr
schwer denkbar dass jemand anders sind
als genauso noch als ergänzung diesen
putin den habe ich ja seit 99 miterlebt
ziemlich eng teilweise haben wir selber
erzogen wir haben uns heran gezüchtet
durch unsere immer weiter gehende
duldsamkeit wir haben immer wieder ist
sogar nicht einmal der macher sogar ein
konsens keine dauerhafte normalität mit
putin denkbar das war nämlich der
presseclub nachgefragt auf 5 sind auf
wdr5 ich bedanke mich sehr herzlich für
ihr interesse schönen sonntag noch
machen sie es gut und bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]